the tripartite pact signed by Italy
Germany in Japan was a defensive
alliance which became the backbone of
the Axis powers in World War two
it placed Japan firmly on one side of a
great global conflict that would soon
involved the USSR in the USA and
ultimately lead to Japan's defeat but
why did Japan join the axis in the first
place and what was it hoping to achieve
to begin it's important to contextualize
what Japan was doing at this point and
what it wanted so Japan had been
fighting a war against China since 1937
in order to expand it to an empire and
have access to Chinese resources this
war with China was roundly condemned by
France Britain and especially the United
States with whom Japan's relationship
with had been deteriorating Japan saw
these diplomatic disagreements as a
threat to its own independence and has
more evidence that it wasn't going to be
treated as an equal by the Western
powers as such it sought new allies in
the only two nations that fit the bill
were Italy in Germany Japan had already
joined the anti Comintern pact in 1936
in an effort to hem in the USSR but this
wasn't any sort of formal alliance the
issue that Japanese leaders had was that
they didn't want to immediately
antagonize the Western democracies and
so it dallied in making any formal
commitments in fact Japan was so
cautious during negotiations that
Germany in Italy formed their own pact
in 1939 because they didn't want to wait
any longer
so Japan's reasons for joining the axis
after all that delay is somewhat
complicated there was a strong belief in
Japan that Britain and America were
trying to build an anglo-american
cultural and economic to Germany across
the world and thus in Japan's eyes it
had to fight this lest it become nothing
more than a mere puppet many in Japan
saw a Wars inevitable and so sought to
join a defensive pact with Germany in
Italy in order to deter and thus delay
the United States from coming to China's
aid however the consequences of joining
an anti America defensive pact was that
it confirmed to American leadership that
Japan was now an openly hostile nation
so what about the USSR
well Japan wasn't exactly keen on
communism but its disdain was more about
geopolitical strategy than ideology for
Japanese leaders the Soviet Union was a
potential rival for influence in China
which wasn't something they could
tolerate in fact after Japan joined the
Axis powers it pushed for the USSR to be
formally invited to help resist
anglo-american hegemony shockingly
though Germany said no and so the next
year Japan in the USSR signed a
non-aggression pact so that will seems
pretty simple right well know there is
another reason why Japan joined the axis
that many people don't think about and
that's that Japan was deeply
of Germany in its rising power when
Japan was negotiating the tripartite
pact the Netherlands and France fell to
Germany thus Japanese leaders were
concerned that this would mean that
Germany would soon be in control of both
French Indochina and the Dutch East
Indies whose resources Japan deeply
coveted as though these negotiations
were going on Europe look like this and
so Japanese leaders were confident that
Germany was going to win as such if it
wanted to pry colonies away from
Europeans it felt that it needed German
backing and to force Germany's hand it
declared the creation of the Greater
East Asia co-prosperity sphere or the
gay acts for short
this was to be Japan's rightful sphere
of influence in East Asia in which they
were tolerate no other great powers
all of this said not everybody was keen
on the signing of the pact and
especially naval officers were concerned
that it was Germany simply outsourcing a
naval war to Japan and with that Japan
joined the Axis powers to summarize
Japan joined the axis for several
reasons to protect himself against
foreign intervention in its war against
China to create a coalition opposed to
any anglo-american hegemony and to
secure its acquisition of resources and
territories in Southeast Asia which was
actually concerned Germany was the
biggest threat - I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
the special thanks to my patreon
supporters James Bissonnette Colin
Castleman danny Maloney Marvin Castle
Rob Waterhouse John BJ's Mo Aaron the
white Michael Reynolds James Castaneda
Gustav Swan Marcus Ozma Jordan Longley
James Castaneda Gustav Swan Marcus Ozma
Jordan Longley Gareth Turner mr. show
Rashid Ali spinning three plates filled
- oink oink David Silverman Izzy
Winston Cawood Maggie packs Kowski Lexi
Schwinn Spencer Lightfoot Kelly
moneymaker
Robert Wetzel Skye Chappelle and Anthony
Beckett